основні плани прем'єр-міністри сановні
плани посол у мінгареллі
чиновна по ній директор сербам синів
зрозумілого нове ми з правді заради 1
Ви буваєте такий форум на такому
високому політичному рівні тому що
професіонал технічного свята
як фактор розвитку
соціально-економічного
в Україні маринад випадкового лику
значення і тут із сферою оккаму і
привести на майдан шик дуже багато
партнерів ціни чоловіка срубає і 1
міністерство звитою наукою тут - амура
биті в партнерстві мишу поруч
парламентом і робота та фц і ми ми широкі
гатчині європейського фонду вас вигляд і
задушити глибокий аналіз сфери
професіонал технічні квіти в Україні та
також зрубаної стука зору
децентралізації ролі органі замість
самого ряду і готовності дати їй
реформи
а також ролик сихендж їх партнерів у
модернізації системи професіонал
технічні його почти я думаю що
детальні вмовляння немає силу аналізу буде
вже корисливою з точки зору цієї отрути ми
моєму рухати себе в наші терміни
щоб зруби тієї правої не курок і
і назвали до ти так ось я до відома і
процес говори вже прем'єр-міністр
модернізація професій на технічні
почти c1s пріоритетів та ряду та
проблем групи , вату ревнивого
управління фрейду централізації в
україні харчування оптимізацію великі
раціоналізації мер шукай професіонал
технічних початкових закладемо так вже про
ітани акривних твій управління змін і
системи управління прав та сильну
технічну а святу та зрощення
автономії початкових закладі та абсолютно
критично
харчування для нагайнови рішення
державного приватного партнерства у
сфері професіоналів і ми моєму реалії
cisco народження динаміки та скоро вчення
контингентів професіонал технічних
початкових закладок погуляйте
всього лише за три роки і у продаж з
2014 по 16 чи хтось за сир і
адже 320 3000 до 280 і 2000 шуму та дтп
скоро вчення про крем демографічних
факторів і йшли
іший фактор фактор носковий ременя
престижності професійні про святи і як
що сьогодні в Україні чуючи 14 адже сотки
випускники в загальна вас
початкових зі кладем прибирає зі видобуток
prophecy технічні свити то в середньому у
в Європі c40 випускники
а у чехії хорватії австрії фінляндії
адже сотні випускників для того щоб
примати пишу професію розлом з повною
за вільну середню святу і з дізналася
що дуже довго професій на технічного
свято булана мар'їної осі у вови уря gif
і ми по ви не подумати і як розум робот
вдасться маяки нашими партнерами бо вони
затікала не у кваліфікованій робітнику
силі
досягнутий за раз і нижчого ременя
престижності професій на ios вигляд і шуми
в той же час зарубав через дуже коротку годину у
нас ауре de papier шифру вейдена
децентралізація фінансування для
професіонала технічні почти олаф
цивілізований спосіб я за 1 відсоток
додамо розрубане проекти законі запитання
вид біля річки і включають харчування
професіонал технічні святі та про
професій та свиту проект закону до
передачі на національне агентство
prophecy інших кваліфікацій оце сам це
агенція центральний провайдер
потім ми можемо встигнути проц його ти пост
стандартних прав і сильних ios адже
стандартах ззовсім спектром професій про
національної рамки прав та сильних
кваліфікацій на сьогодні тут їздять тут
і дірком і на моєму інституті
майдан джека
як і робите не хотіла клич погоди не
затвердила регіональний план та розвитку
prophecy але технічні про sweet & yaki у
регіонах приведення до потреб
регіонального ринку прибрати та
адже крито 25 нових початкового
практичних центрі створа
центрі блуза і вас перебування в ж в
рамках державна приватного партнерства
за долі роботодавець я змінилася
система їх шістнадцятому уроці ми
практично поклала і в основному все на
органи місава самоуправління по
фінансово не хочеш взути 600 мільйонів
гривень стабілізацією на дотація та бог
перевитрати середнє та дотації ми до
допомагав їм і на 50 мільйонів закупив та
обладнання для цик центрі олаф 2017 у 2
мільярда гривень передачі на нас та будь
я за хворі середнього почту в рамках
професіонал технічної є жердина 119
мільйоні для рідкісних професій і знову
е кішка державний для створення кращого
не інфраструктури я tegola поза завданням
уряду ось прем'єр-міністр повернувся то
учасники в конференції ви очі коли
це нам панелек завдання вже починаю
зварюється і порілекс що ми далі вам
вузли
тут у дошка наліво ти дорожня карта
модернізації
сфері професійної sweet поверх на
національному рівні нам усередині
мати руку над цим ринком проти там і
що я регіональна специфіка али ми не
можемо взводу ти потреби про продукт
увальня кваліфікаційних кадрів та
конституційного права
атр і маня піші професії безкоштовно
сільські до підриву конкретного місця
населеного пункту там у це дуже увійшла
його оптимізація мері ліцеїв показано як
у наших індикаторах викл анання плану
уряду шум і виніс великий т.п. tnc і
найбільшим годинникам ставків 2 руки до 2020
уроку сірі дні
їй на повного нести ptmc 397
довести її до 500 осип нових стандартів
прав і сильні а світи що утворюється на
компонент місцевих засідках ми знизали їх
ж рубає і
і будемо удалині питати з наш
ми зарубіжними експертами worldskills з
українськими роботами ми вдасться так і в
стандарті а в стандарті вн і буду без
новлення володіння обладнання висимо
десятих руки в h6 частини 670 їх руки та
цінники технології які нам по три дні та
тому мишу до них міжнародних партнерів
і шука його допомога
адже наших європейських колег і владна
для тут мене інфраструктурних проектів
yaki-da допоможе створи ти нові
навчальний сир і до вище у наших
професій на технічних закладок та зруби
ти їх бито крила бойовими та престижними
ми по ви не переда мій нові права
прав і сенату на prophecy немає нічого
початкові заклади з державне
комуналку в лос низ і для чого нам
потрібно ефективність їх брати з
органами з його самоврядування рожевий
ти державний приватно партнерства
механізми стимулювання всього
партнерства я дякую прем'єр-міністру що
у своєму виступі even піт крісло фцп
тоноване адресою ваших all i said.
я gras росту для профі сенат технічні
світи що сьогодні сьогодні все залежить
вид доброї волі роботу дарсі ось ми
ну ти ж не підписав його воду з буде
вільну палату та україни і я теж рада
що ми досягли взаємних будинковий нас
ти хто яки буду обов'язково конова тілець
що вона ремені законодавства
нормативно-правової бази будуть хоча
відблиски стимули для роботодавець дим і на
їх покладемо
обидва віскі та ківан і може винести а не
пробуватимемо як наповнять і нове вино
у старі міхи у топ топ стару
рамку звучати ще to die ми можемо у
досягнуті реальні я kis на зради з
варення національні agency профі
сильних кваліфікацій як тиски будди
ухвалений закон про світла і ми тут бачимо
наших народних депутатів із парламенту
для нас сократичного важливі тому що
там їдеш терапія кеном та допоможуть
розвивати та професіонал світу в Україні
реформа потреба випивши брати і повного
дружина для уряду
я впав на водіння для парламенту посилені
випасу не місиво влада і бізнес зростав
підсумок дані про світи участь у розробці
стандартів на даня чоловіки вас стати для
практики правильно ви робите цю рамку
прийти будемо ожив його широкомасштабні
за краще не бізнесу я практичні
компоненти навчальний прикраси бази
професіонал технічних початкових за
кладу з головне наше завдання дякую за
увагу